[Music]
welcome back
so today i'm going to tell you about
stokes's theorem and green's theorem
which are vector calculus formulas a lot
like gauss's divergence theorem so they
allow us to relate
surface integrals of the curl of a
vector field
over some surface to the
uh some some equivalent contour integral
around an enclosing contour okay these
are really really useful uh theorems
stokes's theorem and green's theorem and
just like gauss's theorem can be used uh
to express kind of physical quantities
in partial differential equations we can
also use stokes's theorem in a very
similar way
so gauss's theorem has to do with like
volume integrals of the divergence of a
vector field stokes's theorem is going
to have to do with surface integrals of
the curl of a vector field so i'm going
to jump in
okay and essentially we are looking at a
surface kind of an open surface in three
dimensions so the surface is given by s
and we're going to assume that the
surface has kind of a an edge or a
perimeter
that we're going to call uh partial s
now this is just notation this doesn't
mean we're taking the derivative of s
this is just sometimes uh in kind of
manifold theory if you have a manifold
or a surface the boundary uh of that of
that surface has is one dimension lower
so if this is a two-dimensional surface
this is a one-dimensional curve and
sometimes we just denote it by partial s
so this is purely notation
and we're going to assume that you can
have a tangent vector along this pink
curve
so at every point there is a little
tangent vector that we're going to call
d s arrow it's literally a vector with
an x and a y component okay
similarly at every patch on the surface
s
every little kind of
patch
of s
there is going to be a vector in the
normal direction
with area given by d a and so we're
going to call this vector
d a
vector okay
important uh it is it has the magnitude
of the area of that patch and it is
pointing in the normal direction this is
important
good
now
i'm going to write down stokes's theorem
in full generality and then very quickly
i'm going to go to green's theorem
because it's much easier to understand
kind of how things works uh green's
theorem is like a 2d
flat version where instead of a surface
we're just
it's kind of a flat
flat surface and we are working on its
perimeter okay good so stokes's theorem
here is i'm going to write it as
the integral around this entire surface
so the surface integral
of the curl of some vector field and of
course i should always mention there is
some ambient vector field um
you know kind of going through my volume
we're going to call this
big f and it's going to have components
f1 f2 f3 just like it always does
and it's kind of passing through this
volume
and if you like you could also think of
maybe there's just a vector field on the
surface of this volume maybe uh maybe
this is
you know the northern hemisphere and i
have some vector field which is the you
know atmospheric flow dynamics
hurricanes and things
on on that northern hemisphere or you
can think of an oil you know like a
little bubble a soap bubble you can see
the the film um the vector field on the
film so there's some vector field f
that is defined on the surface it could
be a three-dimensional vector field and
we just are looking at how it affects
the surface or it could be a vector
field on the surface itself
and so we're going to take
the surface integral
of the curl of our vector field
and remember the curl of a vector field
itself is a vector field so this is also
a vector quantity
so essentially what i'm going to do is
i'm going to take my vector field i'm
going to compute the curl at every
little patch here every little patch i'm
going to compute the curl of my vector
field
and i'm going to integrate those up all
along the the whole surface
and what i'm going to do is that curl
should be pointing you know i want to
see what is pointing normal to the
surface so i'm going to dot that
with my da vector
so this is kind of like integrating
around the whole surface times d area
but because this is a vector field
itself i'm dotting it into the normal
direction okay i'll kind of give you
some intuition for why that's that's
we're doing this this has a direction a
little bit later
but anyway we're trying to keep track of
all of the curl if we add up all of the
curl of the vector field on this surface
what does that equal sometimes i would
care like maybe the integral of the curl
on that surface tells me how strong the
hurricane
is going to be
and that surface integral just like
gauss's theorem allows us to take and
equate volume integrals and surface
integrals
stokes's theorem allows us to equate
this surface integral to a path or a
contour integral along this pink curve
and so
the integral of my curl over the surface
is equal to
the integral
around the perimeter on this pink curve
of my vector field f
dotted into this little tangential d s
direction
this little d s
and so this is actually a really really
nice expression this is a very easy to
compute quantity i literally just walk
around this perimeter and i i take my f
vector maybe my vector field is pointing
i don't know maybe my flow is pointing
in that direction that's f
and i just dot f with d s and i keep
track of how much of the f vector field
is kind of in this tangent direction
and if i add that up around this whole
curve it basically says how much of f is
kind of swirling around if i am keeping
track of the amount of f that's tangent
how much of that f is kind of in this
tangential direction
and that's a measure of the curl or the
circulation kind of of the vector field
on that perimeter that's that's what
this is
and that's really remarkable
that if i just keep track of how much my
vector field is in this tangential
direction kind of over this closed orbit
again that tells me how much kind of
like circulation or flow
around this uh
this perimeter i have
that is equal to if i computed the curl
at every patch on the surface and added
all of those contributions up so that's
what stokes's theorem is saying and it's
a pretty remarkable theorem
okay so
i want to show you how this works in
green's theorem because i think it's
really a lot easier to restrict this
surface to be flat and look at green's
theorem so that's exactly what green's
theorem is so green's
theorem
is essentially stokes
on a flat
surface s okay so what we're going to do
is we're going to look at kind of a
top-down version of this
where now we have our our surface
s
we still have our perimeter
partial s
and essentially what we're going to do
is write this expression here
but uh looking at at this 2d flat
surface so now my surface is flat
and we're going to do the exact same
thing and i'm still orienting this curve
so that it moves in the i believe
counterclockwise orientation okay that
conforms to the right-hand rule so we
consider this um kind of the positive
direction along that that perimeter
okay good um
now
green's theorem is is exactly stokes's
theorem restricted to uh to a flat
surface
and we can write it down pretty simply
so i'm going to write this down and
we're going to say
now that our our f here
f
in 2d just has two components f1
and f2
and any curl that i have if my vector
field is doing some you know maybe it's
doing some swirly things like this i
have some some kind of like circulation
components you know doing some
circulation
then uh the curl
is going to be pointing out of the board
so any positive curl is going to be in
the kind of k or z out of the board
direction okay so that's why it also
helps to think about this in 2d because
all of the curl is in the kind of out of
plane third component
and so green's theorem or stokes's
theorem on this 2d slice
essentially simplifies to
this surface integral so this integral
over s of the curl of my vector field
now the curl of a 2d vector field is
just
partial f2
[Music]
partial x
minus partial f1
partial y
and now if i think about it every little
area patch the normal is already in the
z direction
so i just have to multiply this by the
little d
d area patch here which is dx
times dy
okay so this is a simpler expression for
this this integral of the curl here i'm
just integrating up the curl of this 2d
vector field over this entire surface
and green's theorem says that this is
equal to
again it's equal to my vector field f
dotted into the tangential direction
into this little tangent direction
so if i take um you know if i have this
little
d s vector
and i have my
f vector i just go along the perimeter
adding up how much what is f dotted with
d s
okay
and so the nice thing is is that this is
uh an integral around the perimeter
of f dotted into the tangential
direction
but because i'm already moving around uh
uh
this this curve that's that's
parameterizing the perimeter this is
essentially just f one
d x
plus f
two
d y
okay so i literally take um how much of
of f
how much of f1 of the
f1 component is in the uh dx direction
of this little
sorry i'm getting ahead of myself let me
slow down
this little ds vector
d s vector is equal to d x
d y
it tells me at every little point here
is my vector moving more in the dx
direction or the d y direction it tells
me what the the direction of my curve is
dx dy
those are the dx and dy here okay and we
integrate all of those little dx's and
dys along this the surface
so this is green's theorem and again it
tells us that i can basically just walk
around along the perimeter of this
vector field adding up this quantity
just literally taking f1 dotted into the
dx
component of this tangent vector plus f2
dotted into the d
y component of this tangent vector
and if i add up that number around this
entire perimeter it equals the sum of
all of the curl of my vector field on
the entire surface
surface integral
so again this is a lot like gauss's
divergence theorem where we're going
from a big integral you know over a
volume down to a smaller integral over a
surface area
here we're going from a big integral on
a surface down to a smaller integral on
the perimeter of that surface and the
same thing here
so here's a couple things i want to do i
want to give you some physical intuition
for why stokes's theorem
and green's theorem are true and then
i'll tell you some cool examples of
these okay
so
maybe the first thing i'll do is i'll
just draw this picture again and we're
gonna do the same kind of pillbox
uh decomposition that we did before for
uh for gauss's theorem
so what we're going to do
is break this up into a number of little
boxes so i have my kind of kidney bean
uh shape here for for the the surface
and we're going to break it up into a
bunch of little boxes
now i've only drawn you know 12 boxes
here but in what we're going to do is
essentially imagine we take the limit as
these boxes get infinitesimally small
and infinitesimally close together so
this is going to be a really really
finely resolved graph paper kind of uh
representing this this area
and so what we can do
is essentially look at the curl in every
little box here
so the little local curl in every little
box
is kind of a little vector field that's
going around in a circle this is a
little positive curl uh representation
here and the next thing is going to have
a little curl these are all going to
have
you know a little bit of curl and i'm
just going to
draw these
and just like gauss's divergence theorem
you can already start to see
what's about to happen
is that
the inner cells
the curl from the neighbors are going to
cancel each other out and so if i
integrate all of these curls over the
entire area all of the inner kind of
components of the curl are going to
cancel out to zero and i'm only going to
be left
with
the component that's kind of in this
tangent direction around the perimeter
and so that's the real idea here maybe i
don't have to draw the whole thing but i
think you get the
the idea hopefully
that just like
um gauss's divergence theorem
if we have these infinitesimal little uh
little boxes
and if we assume that our vector field
is sufficiently smooth that these are
continuously varying from cell to cell
so if f is a smooth vector field and
most of the vector fields i think about
are smooth fluid flows are smooth
typically except for shock waves
the flow over a soap film is smooth and
continuous
and so that basically means that these
different uh kind of components on these
different edges are canceling each other
out this little box is swirling a tiny
little vortex this little box is
swirling a tiny little vortex and the up
component and down component cancel each
other out on every single inner wall
here
and so all that's left
are the little components that are kind
of in this
tangent direction here
that are kind of aligned with the
tangent of the perimeter
and so hopefully that gives you at least
some intuition for why the surface area
of the curl
is equal to a path integral of the
vector field dotted into the tangential
direction the tangent component the the
component of the vector field that is
tangent to uh to this enclosing pink
perimeter
okay so that is uh at least the cartoon
of why green's theorem is true
and stokes's theorem is just kind of a
more general case of of green's theorem
where you now
take this uh this two-dimensional
surface and you imagine that there is
some three-dimensional
uh surface over this perimeter and the
same basic argument applies if i if i
grid this up into little boxes and i
look at all the little curl components
all of the inner
kind of inner walls are going to cancel
out and the only component that's going
to be left when i integrate over this
entire blue surface area is the part of
the vector field that is tangent to this
pink perimeter curve
so again the integral of the curl of f
over this entire surface
is going to equal the integral over the
little contour
the perimeter of my vector field dotted
into the tangent direction just the
tangential component
and this is really cool if we think
about you know let's say we're talking
about planet earth and so we have um you
know we're going to look at the
the northern hemisphere here and let's
say i have a big um
you know i'm not sure i can draw a big
hurricane but let's say i have you know
some
some big hurricane forming in the
northern hemisphere
if i added up all of the curl of every
little patch on this northern hemisphere
that would equal to the amount of the
vector field integrated
along this perimeter dotted into the
tangent direction
and so you can think about it if this if
this surface if this vector field is
swirling you know around in the surface
there will be a signature of that
swirling on this pink perimeter here and
we'll be able to compute
kind of how much circulation or
vorticity there is in this surface just
by computing what is the accumulated
amount of circulation on this uh this
perimeter here
so it's a really powerful idea
and this is going to be useful uh for
things like fluid flows where we have
circulation
and rotation so this is actually really
useful when we think about um
airfoil theory so if i have a wing
i might want to compute kind of how much
uh
what is the circulation of flow kind of
over that wing
and that that will be
relevant for computing the lift over the
wing things like that
so you know curl and stokes's theorem
are really important when we think about
aerodynamic surfaces and fluid flows
over aerodynamic surfaces hurricanes
things like that and and this is going
to be how remember divergence theorem
is how we encoded conservation of mass
conservation
of momentum into navy or stokes
equations
stokes's theorem is how we're going to
encode conservation of angular momentum
so all of this curl is kind of measuring
how much angular momentum i have and if
i add up all of that angular momentum
there's a signature of it in the
perimeter
of that surface
so really really powerful idea here
and one last thing i'll point out and
this is just something neat i i remember
one of my favorite calculus teachers in
high school taught us this and i think
it's a really cool idea
you can also use
green's theorem or stokes's theorem
to compute the area of a tract of land
so back before gps back before you could
just kind of use satellites and gps to
compute the area of an irregular shape
of land or use a computer program
surveyors would actually have to walk
around the boundaries of of someone's
property so maybe i have a farm here
and i have another farm here
and i have another piece of land here
and maybe there's a river
you know that's going uh
you know on the boundary of these
how do i compute the area you know how
many acres or how many hectares of land
are inside this area if i want to sell a
parcel of land and it's gotten a regular
boundary
well it turns out you can use stokes's
theorem for this in a really clever way
so let's say i pick you know one of
these areas here s one of these
irregular shapes s
then the area
of s
is equal to
one half
times the integral around its perimeter
around the perimeter of s
of x d y
minus y
d
x
and i'll tell you why this is true so
this is true
uh and so what i can literally do is i
can walk around i can go you know i
bring an apple and a nice book and i'm
walking around this perimeter and i
literally count
you know how many times i step in the d
y direction versus how many times i step
in the dx direction as i go along this
perimeter and i add them up in this
formula so i literally as i walk around
this perimeter i compute this quantity
and when i come back to my starting
point i will have swept out the area of
s
now why is this true
this is true specifically because our
vector field here
this corresponds to a vector f
that equals
minus y
x
and so if i think about it the curl of
this vector field so the curl of f
is equal to partial of f2 with respect
to x that's one
minus partial of f one with respect to y
that's minus minus one
so this curl equals two
so if i do a surface integral
over s
of the curl of my vector field
d a
that should equal
two
times my area two times uh
this area let's call it a okay
but i don't want to actually break this
up into a bunch of little surface areas
i don't want to actually
parcel this out to measure the area so
we're going to use stokes's theorem or
equivalently green's theorem because
this is a flat surface
to instead integrate around the
perimeter so this
is equivalent
to the same integral around the
perimeter
of my vector field f
dotted in the perimeter
tangent direction
and again f dotted into the primitive
the perimeter tangent is minus y in the
dx direction
plus x in the dy direction that's what
this quantity is
and so if i just integrate this quantity
around the perimeter it's the same
as two times the area of the parcel so
that's why i divide by two here
so long story short if you want to
measure the area of an irregular shape
you can just walk around the perimeter
and compute this quantity along the
perimeter of the surface and
and you can then get the area
so one of my favorite examples of this
is you can compute the area of pretty
interesting shapes like these hyper
hypocycloids
just by kind of parametrizing this and
walking around the perimeter computing
this quantity
okay so that's stokes's theorem and
green's theorem it essentially allows us
to quantify conservation of angular
momentum or curl or vorticity in these
kind of rotational flows in a similar
way to gauss's theorem for uh kind of
you know quantifying conservation of
mass using divergence
um it turns out mathematically
there is kind of a higher dimensional
and n-dimensional generalization of
stokes's theorem and gauss's theorem and
you can almost kind of unify those it's
a little bit outside of it's a little
bit more sophisticated than what i can
show you with kind of simple vector
calculus it's more uh doing calculus on
n-dimensional manifolds but it's really
really interesting um interesting kind
of concept that you can actually
generalize this to n-dimensional
surfaces
okay good so stokes's theorem green's
theorem
in the next few lectures we will likely
be talking about things like potential
flow and which vector fields have
rotation which vector fields are
irrotational and things like that all
right thank you